it's 2015 we've got pictures of Pluto
that looked like this Doc Brown and
Marty have arrived from 1985 and it's
the hundredth anniversary of general
relativity welcome to the science Asylum
I am Nick lucid in a previous video I
gave you an overview of what Einstein
had to say about gravity and you told me
three and a half minutes wasn't enough
remember you asked for this general
relativity says that massive things will
curved paths that would normally be
straight lines but that can be really
confusing if you've never seen anything
like this before
so let's start with a simpler question
what's relativity to understand that we
really need to go over some history it
all starts in 1632 with a crazy italian
guy named Galileo while he was busy
sticking it to the man
aka the Vatican he suggested amongst
other things that all physical laws
should be the same in every inertial
reference frame or IRF what's a
reference frame I guess that does sound
like some complicated science thing but
it really isn't typically physics uses a
coordinate system or frame to refer to
measurements so your reference frame is
just the coordinate system attached to
your body
it's your physical point of view so what
does it mean for that to be inertial
physically the word inertial just means
that motion stays the same so an
inertial reference frame is just a
coordinate system that moves with a
steady speed in a straight line but
let's give this some context here we
have awkward am standing on the ground
and chauffeur clon driving a car
both have coordinates systems of a
steady motion and both completely agree
about what forces are involved the laws
of physics are the same this is a weird
consequence though they don't agree on
who is moving awkward and would say the
car is moving but chauffeur clone would
say awkward Emma's movement no no
awkward Emma's on the ground so she's
the one that's sitting still right false
the ground is moving due east at 770
miles per hour since the earth is
rotating the earth also goes around the
Sun at 65,000 miles per hour
I could go on but I think you get the
point the important thing to understand
here it's not just that you can't tell
who's moving and who's sitting still the
inertial motion is relative which means
both awkward em and chauffeur clone are
correct
all measurements of motion are correct
even if they disagree
that's relativity and it's not just
limited to the motion of the frames
if chauffeured cloade is driving at 20
miles per hour and then throws a ball at
30 miles per hour
akward ed will see the ball moving at 50
miles per hour but the clothes only sees
the ball moving at 30 miles per hour but
how does Einstein fit into all of this
okay this kind of relativity is called
Galilean or classical relativity
it's another 273 years before we get to
Einstein there's way more timeline to go
through the story is important okay he
solved the major problem 273 years later
back to the timeline crazies so 1632
relativity was born and then pope urban
the 8th put Galileo under house arrest
for the rest of his life from 1665 to
1667 Cambridge closed due to an outbreak
of bubonic plague and a rebellious
undergrad college student named Isaac
Newton was sent home that gave him the
free time to develop his laws of motion
calculus synoptic stuff and his
universal law of gravity which was far
from universal even then he published
none of it until 1687 because he didn't
want anyone else to know how to do it
selfish due to head anyway everything
was going just fine until some jerkface
named James Maxwell showed up in 1865 he
discovered that not only was light an
electromagnetic wave but also that this
meant that the speed of light was a
universal constant what what yeah this
is a serious problem how is that a
problem sure maybe if you only think
about it for a second you're like man
whatever but we don't do any of that
shallow thinking here in the asylum
Asylum crazies thing date remember
awkward em and chauffeur clone awkward
em would say the car is moving but
chauffeur clone would say awkward Emma's
movement remember both are correct
that's relativity and it makes perfect
sense if we're talking about a ball but
what happens if we try this with light
say you're in a spaceship zipping past
my space station at half the speed of
light and then you turn on the Ted
lights you would see the light move
forward at the speed of light but do I
see it move forward at one-and-a-half
times the speed of light no I also see
it move forward at the speed of light
the speed of light is a universal
constant so everyone has to measure it
exactly the same no matter where they
are or what they're doing houston we
have a problem
Leo says all motion is relative and then
230 years later Mac smells all like well
not relate so now we have two competing
theories of motion as Galileo writes is
Maxwell writes the debate raged on for
four decades suggestions of universal
reference frames measurements of the
speed of light at multiple directions
and then finally in 1905 Albert Einstein
showed up on the scene with five papers
measurement of the mole Brownian motion
photoelectric effect equals mc-squared
and a crazy but brilliant suggestion for
our problem
what if Galileo and Maxwell are right
the only way they can both be right is
if we're wrong about everything else
completely wrong no no just a little
wrong if the speed of light is the same
for everyone then nearly every other
measurement must be relative time
distance length energy momentum they
must all depend on your point of view
we call this Einstein's special theory
of relativity or just special relativity
for short because it only works in a
special case when you're taking
measurements in an inertial reference
frame if you want to take measurements
in an accelerated reference frame one
that isn't moving steadily in a straight
line then we're going to need a more
general theory of relativity or general
relativity for short but we have a minor
issue physics isn't built on the things
that are relative it's built on the
things that stay the same like the laws
of physics between reference frames
we're quickly running out of things that
stay the same Einstein solved this
problem too but it took them another
decade what happens in accelerated
reference frames hmm let's take a look
at one are you sure you've got this yes
yes I got this all right let's say
there's a ball hanging from a car
ceiling when the car is sitting still
the ball hangs straight up and down
there's a force of gravity pulling down
and a force of tension pulling up if it
accelerates the ball swings toward the
back of the car awkward M who's standing
outside doesn't see anything all that
strange the car is accelerating forward
and the extra tension is what also
accelerates the ball forward so
everything makes sense in the car we
have a problem everything in there looks
like it's sitting still there's no
acceleration so the only explanation is
there must be a new force on the ball so
what's the new force you know my
merry-go-round videos I called it a
fictitious force because it doesn't
exist from all points of view it exists
inside the car but now
outside the car a force is just an
interaction between two or more objects
the tension is between the ball and the
string and gravity is between the ball
and the earth but where does this new
one come from it doesn't appear to come
from anywhere so we call it fictitious
or fake but is it really fake also why
are we treating inertial frames like
they're more real than accelerated ones
shouldn't everybody be on equal footing
either way these are very good questions
and the same ones that Einstein was
asking himself back to the time line so
1905 miracle year of physics a couple
years later good old owl started really
thinking about acceleration it occurred
to him that if you were inside a
spaceship accelerating at 22 miles per
hour per second in a shape proof
soundproof room with no windows it would
feel exactly as if the spaceship was
sitting on the ground we call this the
equivalence principle more often than
not in physics if two things are
indistinguishable then they are exactly
the same thing and it's not just limited
to spaceships remember this ball hanging
in the accelerating car yeah that fake
force is actually gravity there's now a
gravity pulling down and another gravity
pulling backward so the total gravity
points this way which kind of defines
the new down it isn't any different than
if the car was sitting on a hill same
exact physics therefore same exact thing
wait you said that new force was fake if
it's actually gravity doesn't that make
the gravity with the earth also fake yep
gravity not a real force so how does an
acceleration in one frame look like a
force in another for that back to the
timeline in 1908 a guy named Hermann
Minkowski invented a 4d frame called
space-time Einstein wasn't a fan but by
1912 he knew his own approach wasn't
working so he had no choice but to
accept minkowski's the math was a bit
beyond him though so he consulted some
of his math friends and in 1915 he
finally figured it out after
collaborating with David Hilbert general
relativity was finally a thing the
solution some accelerated reference
frames our inertial reference frames
before you freak out let's review
remember physics isn't built on the
things that are relative it's built on
what we call invariance those are the
things that are the same from all points
of view let's make a couple lists I love
lists relative things length distance
time mass
energy motion the list goes on invariant
things the speed of lights space-time
paths electric charge and I think that's
it and cut one of the series we saw a
car moving with steady motion in a
straight line let's take a look at its
space-time diagram as it moves through
space it also moves forward in time
represented by this slanted space-time
path that path is invariant so it's
measured the same by everyone but
separately space and time are relative
from the Clones perspective he's sitting
still in space and only moving through
time on the space-time diagram you can't
change the path it's invariant so you
have to change the frame itself the
Clones time axis lines up with his path
therefore no moving through space the
accelerating clone from this video has
to be treated the same way his
space-time path looks like this but he
also thinks he's stationary so his time
axis looks like this it's not straight
it's curved unfortunately we can't see
the curvature we always see the frame is
straight even when it isn't this makes
things look a little weird and the
equivalence principle set accelerations
we're the same thing as gravity so
gravity isn't a force at all gravity is
just an illusion created by our
perspective it's the result of a curved
or warped frame you think this squirrel
is falling toward the earth speeding up
at 22 miles per hour per second nope
it's moving at a steady speed in a
straight line through curved space-time
you think the ISS is orbit and we're on
the Earth's in a circle
nope steady speed straight line curved
space-time hopefully this cleared up
some things for many of you and maybe
made your brain hurt a little bit it's
good for you every now and then if you
have any questions please ask in the
comments I have a feeling you're
definitely gonna need a comment response
video for this thanks for liking sharing
and subscribing and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy